i'm tara lipinski and my favorite movie
is Gone with the Wind
this movie is very sentimental would
give me courage it would make me laugh
when make me cry it would give me hope
well I think gone with the wind you see
where Scarlett starts out and she has
everything and everything is rosy in her
life and some of her worries are not big
worries and then all of a sudden that
really changes and you have that dip and
then she has to get out of that
I mean Scarlett so sassy how can you not
like her I don't know how young I was
when I first saw gone with the wind
but as a teenager is when I really
started liking it and you look at her
and in her hardest times and she is not
giving up most people athlete or not can
relate to those times where you have to
cling on to hope and you have to push
through and you have to believe in the
impossible
you know you train you work hard and you
hope for the best and then there is this
magic of trusting in faith and hope you
watch a movie like on with the win and
you feel inspired and like ready to go
afterwards you're like I can do anything
I'm Tara Lipinski and I love movies
that's a wrap